este es el último de los problemas que
nos envían con tallo en el cual como ya
te habías dado cuenta involucra
velocidad distancia tiempo pero sobre
todo no es un conocimiento muy duro de
matemáticas para resolver estos
problemas necesitamos solamente un poco
de lógica y algo de álgebra y bueno este
problema dice lo siguiente anam y betis
son dos ciclistas que empiezan su
recorrido simultáneamente anna empieza
en el punto am y betty empieza en el
punto b así que vamos a empezar a
ponerlos por aquí aquí va a estar anam
anna empieza en el punto am y por aquí
va a estar betty betty va a empezar en
el punto b y bueno ambas viajan a
velocidades constantes la una hacia la
otra es decir que a nam va a una cierta
velocidad que vamos a llamar velocidad
subíndice a de ha nam en dirección hacia
betty betty por su parte va a ir en
dirección hacia anam con una cierta
velocidad constante vamos a llamarle vez
subíndice b
y bueno después dicen que después de 30
minutos ellas se cruzan entonces en un
cierto punto ellas no se van a cruzar
vamos a suponer que es este punto de
aquí en este punto se va a cruzar tanto
alan como betty van a pasar una al lado
de la otra y lo que sabemos es que es
después de 30 minutos
así que si yo me fijo en esta distancia
que tengo de aquí hasta que toda esta
distancia pues como la podríamos obtener
pues hay que recordar que la distancia
es exactamente lo mismo que la velocidad
por el tiempo y entonces utilizando esta
fórmula yo puedo decir que esta
distancia es lo mismo que 30 minutos
porque en 30 minutos recorrió esta
distancia na por la velocidad pero anna
tiene una velocidad constante que
habíamos llamado de subir sean por lo
tanto 30 por b subíndice a date cuenta
que esta es la distancia que ha
recorrido a na desde que empezó su
recorrido en el punto a hasta el punto
en donde se cruzan hasta este punto de
aquí ahora vamos a pensar lo mismo para
betty betty por su parte ha recorrido
esta distancia
nos vamos a ir hasta acá ya hasta acá ha
recorrido betty y beijing si utilizamos
también esta fórmula ha recorrido 30
minutos de camino porque ambas se cruzan
30 minutos después de que empezó el
recorrido pero objetiva a una velocidad
distinta a la que va anar betty va a una
velocidad de subíndice de una velocidad
constante por lo tanto esta instancia de
aquí acá la podremos ver como 30 am que
es el tiempo 30 minutos por la velocidad
a la que va a ver bueno y después dice
anna llega en otros 20 minutos al punto
b anna llegan otros 20 minutos al punto
b como puedo ver eso pues bueno esta
misma distancia que recorrió betty en 30
minutos ana la hizo en 20 minutos se
cruzan en un punto y después de este
punto ana sigue pedaleando pedaleando
pedaleando hasta llegar al punto b y lo
logra hacer en 20 minutos así que esta
distancia es lo mismo que el tiempo que
son 20 minutos por la velocidad pero de
que estamos hablando de anna
por lo tanto 20
por la velocidad de anna muy bien y
justo aquí está la clave de este
problema si nosotros entendemos que esta
distancia es inmutable no cambia y por
lo tanto esta distancia es la misma
tanto para betty como paraná entonces
esta distancia yo la puedo ver como 30
por la velocidad de betty o en todo caso
como 20 por la velocidad de anna después
me preguntan en cuántos minutos en
cuántos minutos después de que anna
llega al punto b es decir después de que
anna llega hasta acá llegará vete al
punto a es decir cuánto tiempo después
de que anna llega a este punto va a
llegar vete a este punto se cruzan así
que para camps betis sigue para cam y
bueno se supone que anna va a llegar
antes y entonces efectiva a seguir
pedaleando hasta llegar al punto a
cuánto tiempo más en minutos va a ser
betty este recorrido de esta distancia
es decir va a finalizar su recorrido yo
lo que quiero saber es en cuánto tiempo
va a ser esta distancia y bueno para eso
lo primero que quiero que te fijes es
justo
en esta distancia de aquí y yo sé que
esta distancia es igual para las dos por
lo tanto yo sé que por una parte de ti
lo hizo en 30 minutos y lo hizo a una
velocidad de subíndices a la velocidad
de la que iba betis pero por otra parte
esta misma distancia la recorrió anna en
20 minutos y la recorrió a una velocidad
debe subir desea es decir que 30 v
subíndice bm es igual a 20 veces
subíndice am y como puedo encontrar esta
igualdad porque esta distancia la misma
esta distancia según mi fórmula es lo
mismo que 30 por la velocidad a la que
iba betis por una parte pero esta misma
distancia es igual por esta misma
fórmula a la velocidad a la que iba a
anna por el tiempo que fueron 20 minutos
y bueno si de aquí yo quiero despejar a
la velocidad de anam entonces voy a
obtener que la velocidad de anna es
exactamente igual a 30 entre 20 por la
velocidad de bt y bueno 30 entre 20 es
lo mismo que tres medios es decir que la
velocidad de anam la puedo ver como tres
medios de la velocidad de betty ok y
esto de que me va a servir bueno ya
encontré una forma explícita de
encontrar la velocidad de anna en
términos de la velocidad de betty pero
yo sé que esta distancia
anna la recorrió en 30 minutos a una
velocidad a la que iba a la velocidad
constante a la que iba a anna por lo
tanto si ahora de aquí sustituyó el
valor de anna voy a poder encontrar esta
misma distancia pero ahora expresada en
términos de la velocidad de betty y
bueno entonces vamos a hacerlo pero ya
sé que la velocidad de anna es igual a
tres medios la velocidad de 20 por lo
tanto en lugar de la velocidad de anna
voy a escribir tres medios de la
velocidad de betty y que me va a quedar
30 que va a multiplicar a tres medios
por la velocidad de betty es exactamente
igual que esta distancia que tengo aquí
y bueno
por 390 entre 12 45 45 por la velocidad
de betty es igual a la distancia que hay
desde el punto am hasta el punto en
donde se cruzan ahora recuerda que la
distancia es igual a la velocidad por el
tiempo betty y va a una velocidad
constante de subíndice b y entonces esto
quiere decir que el tiempo que le costó
a betty recorrer esta distancia son 45
minutos esta distancia en total la
recorrido betty en 45 minutos pero que
me preguntan en cuántos minutos después
de que alan llega al punto b llegará al
punto a entonces se cruzan y 20 minutos
después ana llega al punto b ahora se
cruzan y en 45 minutos después
betty llega al punto a ahora mi pregunta
es cuánto tiempo es de diferencia de 20
minutos a 45 minutos que fue el tiempo
en que es tardó más de ti para llegar al
punto a pues vamos a hacerlo 45 minutos
a esto le quito 20 minutos pues
lo mismo que 25 minutos es decir que la
respuesta van a ser 25 minutos después
de que anna llegó al punto b es la
cantidad de tiempo que se tarda de ti
para llegar al punto
y ya está y bueno no olvidemos darle las
gracias a cortar yo por mandarnos este
problema